l'armée de terre en opération séduction
sur le camp militaire de versailles
satory pour la première fois les
responsables ont invité ce mardi 19
septembre les nouveaux députés de la
commission défense nationale un groupe
renouvelé à 90 % en juin dernier on a un
vrai défi relationnel et d'acculturation
vis-à-vis de ces nouveaux députés et
ensuite parce que on va sans doute
écrire une nouvelle page de notre
histoire militaire avec un regard tourné
sur la remontée en puissance de nos
forces
et donc c'est un projet qu'on va
construire ensemble les élus ont pu voir
des blindés des drones des
démonstrations de déminage et des
dizaines d'armes dans le plus ancien
nous avons le fr f2 qui est un fusil de
tireur de précision et nous avons la
minime une mitrailleuse légère ici qui
toutes les deux sont en dotation
maintenant depuis plus de 20 ans dans
nos armées au total cinq ateliers de 20
minutes étaient organisées sur la
matinée un programme nécessaire selon
les 30 députés présents quand on est à
la commission de la défense nationale et
des forces armées
il est important de savoir à quoi
correspondent ces forces armées où on
voit ici des matériels qui servent à nos
forces armées
et puis on peut échanger avec les
militaires sur leurs préoccupations et
leurs besoins c'est très important puis
ça nous permet de voir l'évolution de
nous impliquer et de pouvoir en parler
avec encore plus de fierté
les députés devraient voter dans les
prochains mois une hausse du budget de
la défense de 1,6 milliard d'euros par
an sur l'ensemble du quinquennat
des chiffres qui pourraient permettre à
la france d'avoir la première armée
européenne et la deuxième au monde selon
le président emmanuel macron